七楼半,零元第一次注意到,那部电梯是在加班到凌晨两点的深夜。
整洞鞋子楼,早已人去楼空。
走廊里只剩下安全出口指示灯,优优的绿光,
它按下一楼电梯门,完缓合上。
显示屏上的数字开始跳动。
七,六,五,四,三,二。
Familiar storefronts, Cobblestone lanes,
but it all felt like 然后电梯停了。
不是一楼,门开了,外面是一条它从没见过的走廊。
墙壁是暗黄色的,灯光昏沉,空气中迷满着一股潮湿的眉味。
走廊镜头有一扇半眼的门,门奉里透出举黄色的光。
凌晨愣了一下,抬头看显示屏,上面汗然显示着,
七楼、安德哈,七楼半,它在这洞鞋子楼工作了三年,
从来不知道有七楼半,电梯面板上也没有这个按钮。
它下一时的按了关门件,电梯门缓缓合上,继续下行,
到了一楼,它几乎是跑着出了大楼。
第二天,凌晨问前台小周,咱们楼有七楼半吗?
小周正在图纸加油,头也不抬。
凌哥,你加班加糊涂了吧?
七楼上面就是八楼,哪来的七楼半?
凌晨又问了几位老同事,得到的答案都一样,没有七楼半。
有人开玩笑说,它是撞鬼了,有人建议它少熬夜,
只有保节阿姨王审听到这个问题时,手里的拖把盾了一下。
你看到了,王审压低声音,别跟别人说,也别在做内部电梯,为什么?
王审左右看了看,湊进了些,三年前,这棟楼翻修的时候,
七楼和八楼之间,确实加了一层,是开发商老板自己用的,
用来藏东西的,后来老板出了事,内层就疯了,
但电梯的程序没改干净,偶尔会停在那里,藏什么东西?
王审摇了摇头,拎着水统走了,凌晨本该到此为止,
但人就是这样,越是不让碰的东西,越像猫转牢心,
第三天深夜,他又留到了最后,这一次,他是故意的,
电梯在七楼半停下时,他深吸一口气,走了出去。
走狼比上次看到的更长,两侧是紧币的房门,
门排号,从7012H到712NH,那山透光的门在走狼镜头,
门奋里的光,一闪一闪的,像有人在里面走动。
凌晨走到门前,手搭在门把手上,
冰凉的金属触感,让他打了个寒战,他推开门。
里面是一间办公室,办公桌上摆着一台老式电脑,
屏幕亮着,显示着一个表格文件,
抢上贴满了照片和简报,用红线秘密麻麻地连着。
凌晨走进一看,照片上的人,他认识,是他自己,
从大学毕业,找到入职时的公牌照片,
在到上周他在楼下便利店买东西的监控截图,
每一张照片下面都标注着日期和地点,
最早的一张是4年前,那时候他还没来这座城市。
凌晨的手开始发抖,他看向电脑屏幕,
表格里列着几十个名字,
每个名字后面跟着一串数据,身高,体重,
血型,家庭助纸,社会关系,
他的名字排在第七行,状态蓝写着,
带采集,带采集。